you found yourself a Pokemon partner
what happens I'm a world-class detective
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet
[Music]
no no we're not doing that fine I'll
walk I'm trying to get in a hundred
thousand steps this our Pokemon
detective Pikachu your childhood bed as
a Pikachu bed I've never been so
flattered and creeped out at the same
time rated PG only in theaters May 10
welcome to Rimes City a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
tanner I remember you wanted to be a
pokémon trainer anyway yeah yeah really
workout
come in there whoever you are I know how
to use this jeez here we go
I know you can't understand me but put
down the stapler or I will electrocute
you did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me I've been so lonely they
try to talk to me all the time all they
hear is pika pika you can hear him right
you're adorable they can't understand me
kids no one else here I don't need a
Pokemon period what about a world-class
detective because if you want to find
your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
together and that magic is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving you
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you